hey lebron if we could just zoom out and
put this
year and kind of last year into context
and what this
journey was like and sort of how tonight
was a
a culmination of how this season went uh
if if you
agree with that um
i mean pretty much i mean it's kind of
hard to start thinking about like
when we got started the season started
so fast after leaving the bubble
obviously
um you know and i think i was talking to
wes um in the locker room just a few
minutes ago and i said um the one thing
that bothers me more than anything we
never really got an opportunity to see
our
like our full team at full strength
either because of injury or
covet or or something going on with our
ball club this year
we could uh never fully get into a
rhythm um
and never really kind of see the full
potential what we were capable of and um
you know but but all in all you know i
give my hats off uh
to everyone on this team who showed up
every day to work
showed up every day to compete showed up
every day to put in the time and effort
and uh
and obviously fell short of our goal but
um
you know trying to do everything we
could to to be as good as we could be as
great as we could be under circumstances
and also give uh um also want to you
know shout out phoenix too uh monty
williams
book and then that team they were um
they were excellent throughout this
series all of them um so uh much respect
and how did you come through all of this
physically
i guess from the ankle injury on and
what in the off season
having an actual full offseason uh do
for you at this stage of your career
um well it's gonna be very uh it's gonna
work wonder for me
obviously um you know obviously during
the season i don't talk about rest i
don't
i don't even like to put my mind and
frame it to that it makes me weak
um you know so but in offseason you know
i got an opportunity to rest um we had
like three months
to recalibrate get my ankle back to 100
where it was before that atlanta game
and uh you know that's the most
important thing for me everything else
feels extremely well
um you know my ankle was the only thing
that was kind of bothering me well
obviously bother me in the later stage
of the season
and never fully got back to before the
injury but
you know happy i was able to you know
just go out there and
at least try to help our team win